There's something I've learned over the
years about and I'm curious how you
approach this
and I I don't always get it right and I
don't always it doesn't always work for
me, but a psychological strategy when
someone is quote unquote attacking me or
saying nasty things about me that I
don't believe are true or maybe it's
just I don't like their way they're
saying it and I don't want it to
penetrate my heart and my soul
>> and be reactive and defensive and rigid.
and all these things
>> when the when the brow goes like this.
>> Yeah, exactly. One of the psychological
or therapeutic
uh strategies that I learned is to
imagine either a a field, an energetic
field around me that I can see it, but
then it bounces off. Okay.
>> The words, the intention, the energy, it
comes and then it just goes around me
and
>> like water off a duck.
>> Feel like there's a Star Wars reference,
but Yes. Exactly right. Yeah.
>> Or what I'll do is I will separate the
ego from the self and I'll have the ego
over here next to me psychologically.
Yes.
>> And an image of it. The ego of me here.
Yeah.
>> I say, "Oh, they're just speaking to the
ego."
>> Yeah. There's attachment. They're just
they're speaking over here. They're not
actually speaking to me. They might be
looking at me, but it's just redirecting
right here,
>> right?
>> And oh, this doesn't affect me.
>> Yeah, they're talking about that guy.
>> Yeah.
>> And I saw um I think I saw I think it
was Selma Hayek one time talking about
this.
>> Um she was giving examples somewhere
online about how, you know, if someone
spoke to you really poorly in Spanish
and you don't speak Spanish, you're not
going to get defensive, right? you're
just going to be like, "Okay, I have no
clue what this crazy person is saying to
me."
>> Um, okay. So, just act like it's a
different language.
>> It's just different ways of like
>> separating yourself from the hurt or the
the potential pain.
>> Yes.
>> What have you learned
to support yourself psychologically and
emotionally and spiritually?
>> Yeah. when this feeling of panic, stress
comes your way or when potential attacks
come your way emotionally.
>> So, very similar to yours, I in my mind
I visually have a trash can next to
>> Oh, okay.
>> All right. And I can see it. It's one of
those big huge gallon ones. Just the
black
>> shiny. It's You got it. Yeah.
>> And
I see what they're they're saying is
just a shoot. So, I can see the words
coming and I'm sifting
>> because the issue they're telling me is
not the real issue. And so, if I hear
something that's
uh offensive, that's not nice. I just
Okay, that's trash. Let me just I'm just
I in my mind I grab it with my right
hand, lift up, and throw it.
>> Wow.
>> Like that's that's what I'll do with my
with my thoughts. And I'm sifting to
where if they might have led with
something that was snarky,
which our inclination is to grab onto
that and send it back to them. Yeah.
Send it back and Oh, I just I got a good
one coming
>> instead. Yeah, you got it. Instead, if I
throw that one away, if I just trash it
and then I found the one word that they
said at the very end towards the end,
and that was that was the one word. And
then if I focus on that word, then it
all starts to kind of crumble. But
that's I just imagine a trash can.
>> Wow. It's interesting. Now, how do you
not how do you communicate your worth
when someone is being offensive or
adding a little digs underneath their
language? Maybe they're trying to get a
message across um and they're
frustrated, so they're saying a few
things that would be offensive to you
potentially or maybe hurt you or maybe
kind of put you beneath.
>> Yeah.
>> How do you create a boundary consciously
with them so that they don't keep doing
that in the future where it's letting
them know, hey, this this type of
communication doesn't really work for
me. It's not okay. And and owning your
worth.
>> Yeah. while also being able to throw it
away at the same time and not let it get
to you. Like how do you navigate that so
that they that doesn't continue to
happen in friendships or in
relationships or in career
>> right
>> where that doesn't continue like I
understand we can do it once or twice or
three times but if someone's always
doing that to us
>> right
>> how do we create create that boundary
and and cautiously communicate our worth
>> depending on the context about who that
person is you know who who they are in
your life some people you just can't get
away from I mean or family members what
have you but it's a balance of your you
and then what we're going to just call
as what I'm interested in. So if
somebody were going to say something
that's offensive in a way and they they
are pushing me,
it's a much more powerful move, a very
dominant, assertive move to say I'm not
interested
in returning what you just gave.
>> Oh wow. That's a it's a power move.
>> Yeah. Oh yeah. And see it's it
>> so if I say Jefferson, you know,
[sighs] it was pretty idiotic what you
did the other day to me and I I just
didn't, you know,
>> yeah,
>> you just looked like an idiot, but I
what I really want to do is cuz I moving
forward, I want us to go and do this
thing instead, right?
>> Whatever. I'm just
>> I'm with Yeah, I'm with you.
>> How would you respond to something like
like that? So if somebody Well, what you
kind of did was you you like hid it into
something else that they did.
>> So what I I would first do is call that
out. I I hear two points. [laughter]
>> Yeah. And so I'm like I'm not going to
skip that. So
>> Okay. So you want to you want to just
throw the trash away right away. You got
it. You address it.
>> Well, because they're trying to hide the
trash in the good. And so I my response
is, well, I see two different things.
So, that first point, I don't have an
interest in responding to whatever or
I'm going to say, "Well, maybe I did
look like an idiot." But I'm not going
to be I'm not going to be holding on to
whatever message you're trying to to
send to me.
>> But it's a it's much more a dominant
move to say, "I have no interest in
returning what you're sending."
>> Right? I have no interest in calling you
what I saw yesterday. You do or
something like that.
>> You got it. But if you use the phrase, I
have no interest. I have no interest in
in talking about your opinion of my
performance.
>> Oh, interesting.
>> You know what I mean? Like it's
obviously that's not something you want
to start off with cuz that could sound
that could sound defensive. That can
sound issues. But the point of it is
when you say I have no interest, you're
letting them know like I don't have an
it's like you're saying that as you're
doing the trash can thing. I really
don't have an interest in you know what
this this kind of food it's not great
for me doesn't really settle well with
me but what does taste good is what you
said you know about x y and z and so you
kind of imagine those words as part of
let's say it's you know your diet sorry
I'm a little lactose intolerant but
>> right
>> so let's let's skip the milk and talk
about something else
>> what are the three power moves in
conversations
that
really set you up for success ess in any
conversation.
>> Number one is silence, just nothing. So
if somebody were to say something that's
snarky,
the best move is to say nothing. You
just kind of sit back and you look
around and you look up, you look off.
I'm telling you, nine times out of 10,
they can't take it.
>> Really,
>> they can't take that silence because
then
then it's spread out. you've just
exposed instead of you covering it up
with something else that says excuse me
did what did you say
>> you're just leaving it open kind of like
that that really that the best foot
you're going to put out right now that
one
>> you go that the one we're going to
choose
>> and if you just let that silence sit
there often times and you probably heard
this they go I shouldn't have said that
you you got to give them that chance
>> that's number one
>> yeah number one is you got you got to
give him a chance of of that silence
Number two, acknowledge that it could be
without acknowledging that it is. And
you say of saying, "Well, maybe so.
Maybe you're right."
>> And not say you're right.
>> No,
>> but maybe you are.
>> Maybe, maybe you're right. But it's that
piece of humility that says, "Yeah,
well, maybe you're right."
>> I had a guy once who said, uh, I was
deposing him and, you know, all these
all you lawyers, worst things that ever
happened to America come and talk. And I
said, "Well, maybe you're right, but
today it's just going to be a
conversation between us."
>> Is it okay if you're just talking to
Jefferson? And he said, "Yeah, I can do
that."
>> Wow.
>> And so, it's that ability to just say,
"Well, maybe so, but I could have I
could have gotten really defensive with
him. I could have I could have chosen to
taken that personally instead just
dropped it." Uh, the other power other
power move is to hold off on the timing.
So when you are mad, that's generally
not the best time to do it. When like
when when you know you've done something
wrong, you want somebody to be mad at
you to like fight me, please. Like I
know I've done something wrong. I Let's
Let's have this out. We'll talk about
this. You You want to talk about this at
Let's talk about Let's put it in the
calendar for tomorrow.
>> You got it. Let's Oh. Oh. Well, I'm
Okay. It's Well, I'm I'm glad I'm glad
you said that. Well, then, you know, I
don't really have my thoughts together
on that, but
why don't we car to talk about that at
noon tomorrow? What do you think? Now,
they're like, "Oh my god, like I just I
just said something that
>> I shouldn't have said."
>> But that's that's a much better way of
of uh of handling it because at that
point, you have not lost any confidence.
You have not lost your credibility.
>> You just you've maintained that you're
the one in control at all times. I'm
telling you, the key is just starting
with your breath
>> and choosing to be quiet,
>> right?
>> If you were if you were to say something
to me and I responded right away, like
if you were to say, um, I don't know, do
you do you um do you enjoy matcha tea? I
go, no. Versus me thinking,
>> no.
>> Like there's just a different
connotation to it when you think about
it.
>> Yeah. Um about 14 years ago,
um
someone gave me a a line that became one
of the most powerful uses of language
over the last 14 years to help me get
almost anything I want or more of what I
already have.
And I use it all the time. When I go
uh order a coffee, I use it. When I go
to a hotel and try to get an upgrade, I
use it. When I'm working with uh
partners and collaborators, I use it.
And the line is, what's the chance?
What's the chance you can give me a
discount on this? What's the chance you
can give me an upgrade in this hotel
room?
>> What's the chance you can give me in
first class?
>> Yeah. What's the chance we can
collaborate in a bigger way?
>> Yeah.
>> What's the chance you can go a little
more on this?
And
I've used that over and over again
because it continues to work. And I
almost use it as a game daily. Like
>> any store I go into, I'm just like,
>> what's the chance you got 10% off on
this?
>> Yeah.
>> Just to see if you can make something
happen.
>> Cuz if you don't ask, you're not going
to get it.
>> Right.
>> And um it's just like a way to be
playful. It's a way to like see can I
enroll someone in something that I maybe
I shouldn't be getting but I would get.
>> Yes.
>> And it often works where the unexpected
happens. Is there another
line of communication that you use maybe
even unknowingly that you use
consistently that seems to
>> just help you enroll people in more of
what you want?
So I do I absolutely use the what's the
chance really? Yeah. So I I will use
that when it feels like a surface like a
stalemate between the other attorney
>> and look what's the chance that your
client's going to be able to do
>> X Y and Z.
>> Also I will try to separate the attorney
from the client. the same way I do with
like the reception clerk versus the
hotel. I I I make sure that I
acknowledge them as the person because I
acknowledge their struggle of what
they're going through,
>> right?
>> And so if I talk to the attorney of
look, I can only imagine, you know, all
the updates you're you're having to do
or all the work you're putting through.
I I know that this is how you're doing
the best thing you can for your client.
I mean, between me and you, what what
what's the chance that we can do X, Y,
and Z? or if I were to do or if I were
to say or if my client were if I were to
encourage my client to do this,
is that something that I should do?
And it gives them something to think
about,
>> right?
>> The same way like at a let's say at a
hotel or something like that, I I can
only imagine you just been how how
long's your shift?
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. 7 hours. Oh my gosh. Yeah. That's
going to be And so you just Yeah. you
kind of create that connection with them
that says I'm talking to you
individually as a person rather than
seeing you as the whole then because
that's who they are.
>> Yeah, exactly. That's powerful.
>> If you enjoyed that clip and want to see
the rest of the conversation, you can
click right here. Or if you want to see
the latest episode of the Jefferson
Fisher podcast, click right here and
I'll meet you